what is
this
oh yeah it's another average disney plus
reboot of the classic storyteller by the
dozen which was based on the 2003 steve
martin film which was based on the
original 1950 film which was based on
the 1948 novel also titled cheaper by
the dozen this retelling of the baker
family story starring zach braff and
gabrielle union has very little to do
with the other stories though in fact
the previous stories all had 12 kids
while this story has 10 kids and two
parents so it's not quite the same dozen
as you might think disney has an odd
knack of grabbing any low-hanging fruit
that's sure to make them some easy money
especially when it comes to sequels and
reboots typically they don't take as
much time or effort to produce and
they're usually able to slap an easily
recognizable name on the poster so they
get lots of viewers 2022's cheaper by
the dozen is no different for the most
part and pretty much follows the new
disney formula for reboots of classic
films while also trying to touch on a
bit of social commentary in a kid's
movie anyways we'll get to that later
for now let's talk about the opening
scene
the first scene introduces us to zoe and
paul baker two former divorcees who met
at paul's breakfast restaurant they
eventually got married and brought kids
from their previous marriages together
into one home along with two sets of
twins they had together now i know what
you're probably thinking this sounds
more like the movie yours mine and ours
than cheaper by the dozen and i'd
probably agree with you if the movie was
made in 2006 i think disney was simply
trying to show that mixed families are a
normal thing and not something people
should be ashamed of so it's nice to see
a different take on what a family can
look like other than the typical nuclear
family we're also introduced to each of
the baker children and gets some not so
necessary narration on their hopes and
dreams movies like this often fall into
the trap of telling us things to
introduce the story rather than showing
us things which is much more
entertaining to watch anyways the scene
also introduces us to kate paul's
ex-wife who is probably one of the worst
babysitters of all time what are you
guys playing drag race oh fun i love
rupaul she does however help zoe and
paul get all the kids out of the house
on time for the day we're also
introduced to the family's two dogs bark
obama and joe biden and i mean come on
that's kind of funny the movie does have
a couple of funny one-liners too
that's my daughter yes that's also my
daughter biologically she's mine yeah i
claim her on my taxes okay this line
actually brings me to my next point one
of the movie's main focuses is on
insecurity specifically paul's which is
only heightened when zoe's ex-husband
dom comes back into the picture paul's
threatened by dom and tries to do
everything he can to be successful to
give his kids everything they want but
eventually goes too far focusing only on
his work rather than on making his kids
and his family happy his insecurity
comes to its height at halftime during
their daughter's basketball game where
paul and dom face off in a dance battle
which is probably one of the most
unrealistic things about the entire
movie i mean what high school willingly
cuts their dance team's number short so
the crowd can watch two random guys
dance pretty poorly anyways next we find
out that paul has been asked to present
his special sauce to a group of
investors since it can be either hot
sweet or savory depending upon what you
put it on the investors are impressed
and provide them with seed money to
begin selling his sauce in grocery
stores this presentation is what
eventually leads paul down the rabbit
hole to his family's unhappiness he
uproots them from their humble cottage
in echo park and moves everyone to
calabasas then there's a few scenes
which are just there for feel-good
family movie filler and they show how
the big family just lives as a big
family which i can appreciate coming
from a large mix family myself as
they're unpacking though a security
guard informs them of a noise ordinance
for the neighborhood naturally he goes
straight to zoe who's the lone black
woman in the neighborhood it's at this
point when you start to understand one
of the main messages the film is trying
to get across kenya barris jennifer
reichskenzik and gail lerner all three
of whom worked on the hit series
blackish managed to sprinkle in some
lessons about the complexities of racial
identity in the film within the typical
messages about family understanding and
forgiveness for instance zoe instructs
her kids not to bring their toy guns to
the pool for fear that they might be
treated differently simply because of
the color of their skin and it's
understood that this is absolutely not
the way that people should have to live
their lives the writers did a pretty
good job of intermingling this social
commentary within the plot of the movie
and while some critics may say it was an
unnecessary addition to the film i think
it added something which parents or
other adults might appreciate in an
otherwise boring family film and it's
something that many people probably
needed to hear after selling the special
sauce for a while paul gets an
opportunity to franchise his restaurant
while zoe is hesitant she supports his
dreams but begins to struggle to keep up
with the kids haresh is getting into
fights deja is missing basketball
practice dj is struggling with how to
talk to girls and seth is struggling
with just fitting in with the family
this is when the story starts to get
pretty predictable even if you haven't
seen it yet you can probably bet that
we're about to enter what i call the pit
of the movie the pit is basically the
low point in predictable family movies
or rom-coms where the main characters go
through a breakup or a big fight that
eventually leads to forgiveness where
they all live happily ever after and
that's exactly what happens in cheaper
by the dozen paul says he has to stay
away for business for an extra week
meaning he would miss dj's birthday
party zoe hits a low point in taking
care of the kids all by herself and they
have a huge fight also it seemed as if
paul wasn't going to make his flight
back home in time so he would miss the
party entirely but as you might have
guessed paul was able to get back home
just in time quit the franchise business
move his family back to echo park and
live happily ever after although it was
a pretty predictable third act it still
left me feeling good about the movie's
outcomes perhaps that's why films like
this are so predictable so we feel a
level of comfort in knowing that it's
almost guaranteed that everything is
going to be okay it gives us a sense of
escapism because we know everything will
turn out alright while still taking
place in a somewhat realistic world
overall the new cheaper by the dozen
doesn't really make sense to anyone
who's coming in thinking it's going to
be a similar story to the steve martin
films and a lot of the themes in the
movie might not make sense to the target
audience kids but to parents or other
adults watching i think the movie might
have a little bit more to say than just
a typical family feel good movie all in
all it's a not so adventurous pretty
average disney movie worth a watch if
it's something you're interested in but
not necessarily something i'd say you
should go out of your way for anyways
that's going to be all for today if you
like what you saw please check out the
other video on your screen for some more
great content also don't forget to like
and subscribe as it truly does help me
out and thanks for watching rocket riley
you